this is this is like a big time server
so for long webinars this can be really
effective
[Music]
thank you so much for joining 20 minute
leaders
thank you for having me it is so great
to have you i can't wait to talk about
self optimization so
you had a company called super tools and
you
are a walking super tool and tommy over
the next 20 minutes
i want to learn what it means to be
productive i want to learn what it means
to be self
optimized first things first i need you
to stand up
because this is going to kill this is a
killer
just to stand up okay i'm wearing my uh
pajama
yeah what is this okay it's a zoom it's
a zoom shirt
so i can be elegant while i'm doing zoom
calls but uh
you know still still feel comfortable
wearing my pg's
so uh okay let's see next question
because of the end girl you see only the
shirt but actually it's like
this might be unbelievable
yeah my actually my mom i got it like to
send a shout out to my mom because she
made it for me so uh
unbelievable unbelievable okay tommy
first of all
uh i want to talk to your mom second of
all
let's talk about self-optimization what
does it mean
to be productive
yeah so for for me to be productive is
probably
to prioritize and to do
the stuff that really matters to you so
meaning that you know if you if you want
to great growth in your life if you want
to
achieve your let's say goals you need
systems
and by systems i mean you need mental
models and also technology and digital
tools because it's like
real superpowers um to really create
this compound entrance interest of um
of basically self optimization
or self-improvement but why do we need
that i really
why do we need that because we go about
our day you know we're all working we're
working hard we're doing you know
sometimes we work 12
13 hours a day why do we need to
self-optimize if
you know we're getting stuff done so we
live in a very
um let's say hectic times
when you have so much like information
overload
some experts call it like the intention
economy so you have so many things to
read so many things to learn
so many things too um you know
when you open your email you probably
have so many messages that you need to
go through
uh but when you ask yourself what what
really creates
growth around my life around my um
you know what actually makes me happy
what actually makes me a better person
a smarter person and probably
um you know so
think about everything that you want to
achieve in life this is not something
that you will find
on facebook or do you find on twitter
this is something that you need to work
hard
and every day and this is this is
exactly the meaning of compound interest
like
every day like becoming uh one percent
better every day
this is something that uh um that you
you can really achieve
by building your own systems and this is
why i love by
like the fact that we are living in in
the world that you you can create your
own software without knowing
a line of code this is amazing this is
like a great superpower that everyone
can
take and and go um
above the noise and become much smarter
become more talented and more um
resourceful than ever because they
create their own systems their their own
software
around um you know your goals and your
your desires so just to just to simplify
what you're saying is
this notion that if we are if we improve
some aspect of our lives by one percent
every day that
one percent is actually compounded and
actually after a hundred days we've
actually improved
almost sort of 100 percent of our of
ourselves and if we take the time and we
use data and we use software
to to to think more critically about
what we do and soon you're going to show
us
some of these insanely cool features
then we're going to be able to improve
with actually not it's and it's actually
not that hard
to improve once you have the data and
let's just start show me what's on your
on your middle finger on your left hand
because that's one of the coolest things
it's it's a beautiful ring
but it's not a wedding ring right
yeah basically sleep like i'm i'm
fascinated by
by paul multipliers that we have in life
and
some of them are really easy this is
like
you know the fact that sleeping
is so important for so many aspects of
your life
um and still we are compromising our
sleep every night
especially entrepreneurs especially
founders um
i see many founders like um you know
bradley like
they they they share with me the fact
that they are not sleeping well and
they're not
they're not saying it as as like to be
you know as something that uh um yo
sometimes i'm hearing people like
proudly speaking
about the fact that they're not it's a
bragging i'm working hard
i'm not sleeping like uh um i'm sleeping
uh four hours four hours at night
meeting right working
you know very effective and very hard
but the fact that like busy doesn't mean
that you are
productive or effective right it's
probably the opposite like if you are
not
optimizing your day so you're probably
going to compromise your night
and then what will happen in the long
run that
you will be less healthy less focused
less any anything like
that there are so many elements
that you know are affected from our
sleep the way we sleep at night not only
the duration of our sleep but also the
quality of our sleep
that i was amazed by the fact that
there's so many books that can you can
read uh
i believe uh i think the book called
sleep wisely maybe okay i need to check
it out
but i will stand if we have some notes
on on facebook we can send some uh
some links or the tools that i'm going
to share 100
100 yeah yeah sleep wise okay so sleep
wise
is maybe not maybe it's the baby wise
i'm maybe i'm confusing with my uh
yeah with my baby uh baby okay
um yeah this is also important but um i
think that
you know everyone knows that sleep is is
important
but not everyone are taking you know not
everyone are optimizing their sleep and
understand how can
they how can it actually affect your day
because you know this is our defaults
and
we are living with them and our body
kind of adopts
but but in a way when when i optimized
my sleep and this is why i bought the
ring because
i wanted that the first step to optimize
something is
basically observation and
and learning the status quo okay like a
startup so the first thing that you do
you're doing like a market research
you're checking out are your competitors
so you're doing some research so if you
want to improve your sleep you
have to learn what is your current
situation
you have to do some um analysis work
like to understand
and and and that's impossible to do when
you're sleeping because you're sleeping
you're not actually aware but this ring
helps you by giving
you i guess you know a dashboard that
says this is how much deep sleep you've
gotten
this is where you didn't get good sleep
and these are your improvement steps for
the next day right
yeah basically this is the web interface
so it's not very
it's not the the best interface they
have like an app that i can
share with the audience as well but
basically you can see
trends around my sleep not only the
duration of my sleep but also
some cool stuff about cycles like the
stages
so you need um rem and deep sleep in
order to really
um uh to really create a quality sleep
every night so
basically it's around thirty percent of
rem and thirty percent of deep sleep
every night
and it regardless of the duration of the
sleep
um of course between seven to eight
hours is a good sleep
um nine hours is not very good
also but uh you know i'm hearing a lot
of people like
sleeping on average four hours five
hours a night and this is
you know it's so i
i don't have words to say like like how
bad it is
i'm gonna try on you on your 20s so okay
it's fine
your body probably can adapt but but but
you know i'm like on my 30s and i can
tell you that
after i optimize my sleep plug the fact
that
it's it's upon multiply so so many
things your productivity to the way you
make decisions to make you actually run
your day
yeah to your happiness to your love to
everything is kind of affected from from
the way you sleep no i'm actually a
little
i've heard this quite a few times but
tommy you're i mean the things that you
do to optimize your day go
far beyond just the sleep so you're i
mean you
are literally optimizing almost every
single part of your day so i'd love to
spend the next
you know 13 to 15 minutes you know let's
go over
a bunch of the things that you do to
self-optimize because i want to learn
myself
and i think that anybody who sees this
is going to be just fascinated to see
what's possible in the realm of
optimizations
sure so the first thing that i learned
from the book
atomic habits is that it's not
very useful to um to define goals
to set up goals and to set up set up
objectives
for your life it's better to set up
systems
right so if you want to do so if you
want to become someone let's say
i want to lose some weight okay so it's
good to to have like a high level goal
of what you want to achieve
but it's better to have a system that
works every day
um it's much more effective and this is
exactly what i did here so i created a
system called aos which basically
i have levels of things that i want to
improve
and you can see it here so the levels
are reflection body
reading so i want to become smarter by
reading
seek truth i'm drafting stuff so i love
to write stuff i like to network so i
love to meet people
and i also love my family so i want to
also um so every article that i'm
reading every piece of information i'm
capturing
in this space so i have some levels of
life and if you know naval so i took
some inspiration from
his post this is to tweet storm around
um uh you know that it's kind of
he outlines all the important stuff in
life so i just put it here
and i created some spaces around it wow
and basically
um here you can inside of every every
um you know every pillar every level i
have
pieces of information and inspiration
that i took from many people
but here on my day os basically i'm
managing all my information here so i'm
managing
my focus areas like what i want to
achieve this is basically my okrs my
personal okrs
i also have here some rewards so for
every
um every okr that i'm that i'm achieving
for every goal that i'm locking i
get like i buy a gift for myself wow
for example this one i will buy like
this new magic keyboard this awesome
magic keyboard
so this is sort of like a reward system
that i created for myself and this is
why i love
like notion and other platforms that
that you can see now in the world they
are letting no coders so people that
don't know how to code they're letting
them
build their own systems which is great
so basically here
um i can see let's say um
okay so let's open this toggle so here i
have this
habit tracker uh so if we'll add a new
day
um you can see my goals basically but
let's
add a new day here so i'm adding a new
day
basically this is today
next day it should work no okay so june
30.
um basically i'm tracking
i'm tracking a lot of things during the
day with today's wednesday
does this ever become i mean you so if
you do this every day does it ever
become a burden to the point where you
just don't feel like doing it because
it's taking because you just want to get
on with your day
so it should be frictionless and i got
to be honest with notion
because of the lack of api it's not one
100 frictionless but it's still
uh very easy to set up so every day when
i wake up today
i didn't actually do it but every day
i'm actually tracking
my goals and i'm just putting here so
i have like an abbey track effects
they're actually the day so if i'm
checking here
yoga reading working out sleeping well
and then i have some brain food that i'm
tracking so everything that is
i'm not tracking food there's like
everything that i ate i'm just tracking
things that i want to okay it's like a
it's like a white
list of food that i wanna um amazing
that i want to consume
every day so it's a system it's kind of
it becomes it becomes a system
um so you see if i'm eating six
different
um uh types of food from this list
i'm getting this emoji of a avocado here
amazing um you can see it here so i know
that i
let's say i achieved everything so let's
say i um
achieve this one and this one and i did
this
so you can see i'm getting the message
great job tommy automatically this is
like i play with the formula of notion
and again this is all
this is all personally for you nobody
else sees this this is just for tommy to
feel good
about the progress you're making and
then as and and and one of the things
that atomic habits and i read the book
recently
one of the things that that he talks
about the author is
this idea that obviously the incremental
one percent improvements but this idea
that you have
you have to do really small small wins
every day so that you keep on the
momentum and by seeing
these all these icons and all these
emojis you actually have that inner
motivation to continue
but tommy we only have we have exactly
we have we have about six minutes left
and we have so much to go through
so let's let's yeah we have gyro we have
calendar we have so much to go through
so let's let's
just let me let me show you one more
thing here and then we will we can move
to other other aspects of
some you know cool acts that we can we
can showcase but
let's let's talk about like morning
routines so
you probably read a lot of books you
know around morning routine you should
this
you should do this and this and this so
instead of of
of kind of uh thinking what is the
perfect morning routine you can create a
system
a digital system to actually um
do it every day without thinking about
it so i have here
you can see this column this like you
know sun
kind of sunrise uh emoji so when i open
it
i do um several things and i build this
but i
it's really really easy to build so
basically i can read
an inspirational kind of a visual
image that i love by jack butcher i can
put here i can capture what i'm what i
what i am grateful for so i can kind of
do
this ready to the kind of practice this
is the status quo so every day i will
see here
a different style startup quote from you
know different
uh persona that i love um here i do
meditation so basically i have this
audio embedded and i can
just take no a step back through a
on one dashboard i love it exactly that
i built
so let's move on to uh basically
uh this incremental improvement so
becoming every day better so basically i
build a system in notion
um which i can see and i can reflect for
um you know you probably know what is
like
the meaning of a weekly um
reflection or weekly review so basically
it's just
reflecting on your week planning your
next week
seeing how can you improve yourself so i
built a system to do
probably the perfect weekly review for
me
so here what i can see so for each week
i can see
the stuff that i want to improve i'm
actually measuring
three main things i'm measuring my sleep
score
measuring my productivity score from
rescue time
i can show you the dashboard right away
and i'm measuring my l score from
gyroscope so basically this uh the the
elf score
is this is the gyroscope takes
information
from apple elf my aura ring
at the apple watch many aspects the
weather
so many things that you know rescue time
so you can see the focus you can see the
on average
79 focus at work so
it kind of aggregates a lot of
information and
presented to you in a dashboard that you
know you can create
correlations between the different
data points so let's say i want to know
how my resting heart rate
affects my sleep so i can see the
details and i can basically connect
you can see it here so you can you can
see my resting heart rate which is an
indicator for good elf
and i can connect let's say my computer
um stats to see what's going on if my
heart rate is higher
is high on the high side how does it
affect my focus
on the digital space you know i can just
explore explore some some different uh
um correlation between my elf and the
way it actually affects my productivity
and then you kind of become your um
data analysis or like data scientist
of yourself so you kind of you know
you can think about it you can think
about yourself as as a product
as a startup and the way you optimize
yourself is by data
and reading data and effecting on data
and then
um optimizing and thinking now you can
improve yourself
every day every week and so on
unbelievable tommy talk to me about
calendars talk to me about what is what
what is the
what is the importance of being a good
calendar
optimizer and planner
yeah okay so um so let's talk a bit
about uh about the future of calendaring
so what do we do with super tools uh so
after creating
um one of the most biggest productivity
communities in the world
uh we've decided that we want to tap
into the productivity
sas space and create something
that will be meaningful for people so we
started to interview a lot of people we
understood that
one of them that the most
absolute let's say tools that we have on
our digital stack
is our calendar basically from 2006
probably when gmail and when google
introduced the google calendar
uh we haven't seen any innovation around
the most important time system that we
have basically it's just like a
if if i can say a stupid um record
system
uh you can record events but it's
the software doesn't make you better it
doesn't work for you you work for
your calendar right so uh one of the
most
impactful and useful methodologies
around
calendar is time blocking basically it's
a practice when you block
time on your calendar and you take
and prioritize tasks that you have and
prioritize
uh goals and put it put some time slots
on your calendar to work on them
uh but it's it's really
um you know you have a lot of friction
around it because you need to take at
least an hour
of your day to just do this practice and
it's really hard like honestly it's
really hard so as a productivity trainer
i
taught many people how to do this to do
this practice into this workflow
but i believe a good software can take a
lot of the
a lot of the busy work a lot of the hard
work and
basically what we do now we are creating
a calendar that
can help you time block that can help
you
be more engaged with what you want to
achieve and what you want to do
so you can think about it as a personal
um
as a personal kind of assistant but uh
dedicated to make you
a time machine so give me you know give
me one or two pointers about about
what i should be doing with my own
calendar what my friends should be doing
with their calendar
to be to get to get more control over
what we do
yeah and i believe like the the calendar
like the user interface of the calendar
is probably
the most effective things that you can
you can use during your day in order to
um
to become better like i'm tracking
everything on my condo i'm tracking
um like my sleep i'm tracking uh
tasks i'm tracking so many things and
i'm putting everything it's like my
navigation system at work
and i just want to make it better i
think a lot of people are waiting to see
a better version
of our calendar but if i can if i can
give just one tip
uh that you can probably implement from
tomorrow until
uh we'll launch is ask yourself every
day
what is my most important task and try
to book it
on between it can be between
60 minutes to 90 minutes try to book in
the first
um right away after you wake up so and
after your morning routine
try to book it the first thing in the
morning
before you are doing meetings before
you're running any meeting
uh try to book your most important test
just time to work on it
you don't you don't have to finish the
test you just need to
um be accountable to the time and
and you know exactly like
you're accountable to a meeting with
your doctor so i think you have a
meeting with your doctor but
are just you know working on your most
important tasks so and that's
really helps you prioritize and and
and and kind of take intentions into
actions
turn intention into actions and this is
why i love time blocking because
so effective is you know you you feel
the change right away
and obviously one of the most difficult
challenges with this is that
you are you're the only attendee of your
calendar
invite so when something else pops up or
when somebody needs your attention
it's much easier to tell yourself oh
michael yeah i'll just get to this later
when you go to it i'll give you another
tip so this is what we can do together
maybe
so find an accountability partner all
right
let's say let's say you have a task and
i have a test i can send you
um a zoom invite to let's say 90
90 minutes of of focus time okay so we
can be focused together we are muting
the call
you work on your most important desk i
work on my most important test
and we are catching up every like 30
minutes to just
check in what's going on um
accountability bond is it's probably one
of the most effective things that you
can do
um uh for your product to supercharge
your productivity so
um if you are working from home this can
be really really effective and you don't
need any tool you
you can just stand exactly under invite
to your partner i love work on your most
yeah we're doing it a lot
we also have a clock here this is really
cool
um so basically we created the zoom
background
um when oh that's so cool
though yeah so we have sort of like a
pomodoro pomodoro clock so every
so we have we are working with like with
intervals it's called pomodoro
so every time everyone can see this
clock everyone are working on their
and by the end of the session we are
just checking in
going to take coffee uh to the restroom
and
and continuing with the next session
really yeah sorry um yeah
this is this is like a big time server
so for long webinars this can be really
effective so
if you want to go and still be uh
engaged with the meeting so you can
create your own avatar avatar
and tommy show me the one of your
of your living room yeah wait no no
living room
oh this one oh this one yes like uh
when you have this annoying person who
is
getting into the frame i love it
basically you can do a lot of stuff
yeah call me this is my favorite movie
it's also effective to put the agenda of
the meeting here this one is for ebay
amazing yeah many cool stuff so wow
amazing amazing amazing tommy it this is
just fascinating it's and
you know it just it very shows that this
is something that you're so passionate
about and obviously the things you
showed here
are things that you've been working on
for quite some time and and while
there may be a lot of friction to get
into them on day
one on day two the goal is for them to
be to be a frictionless part of your
day and actually just make you that one
percent more productive so i'm sure that
by now
you don't feel that it's a chore to go
and and you know continue managing them
they're already set in place and and one
of the things that i'm i'm making a goal
for myself is to set something
some of these things up for me because i
hold myself accountable to many things
i don't yet hold myself accountable for
my sleep or for
how productive i'm throughout the day
and i definitely feel like i'm chasing
my own calendar i'm chasing the things
that i have to do
instead of taking ownership over them so
thank you for the inspiration
before we leave tommy i need three words
that you would use to describe yourself
well building time machines probably
uh yeah is like the perfect way to
describe
what i what i'm doing and what is my
long-term vision
40 years from now so i always build
like time machines and and and make them
more accessible and
want to democratize productivity to the
rest of the world
i love it tommy thank you very very much
and i can't wait to catch up can we
catch up properly in israel
me too man bye
hey